Look at this watch.
A square case.
Roman numerals.
Screws you can actually see.
It looks perfectly at home under
a jacket sleeve.
But the Cartier Santos begins with
a very different problem:
how do you check the time
while you're busy flying?
Before airport lounges, before airline
meals, before anyone complained about
legroom, a Brazilian inventor was taking
experimental flying machines over Paris.
His name was Alberto Santos-Dumont.
And according to Cartier's history, he
needed a watch he could read
without fishing around in his pocket.
The answer was small enough to
wear on his wrist.
The story became much bigger.
An aviator, a jeweler, and a
practical idea would become one of
the most recognizable designs in
watchmaking.
But the interesting part isn't just
how the Santos was born.
It's how a flying tool became
a luxury icon.
To understand the watch, start with
the man.
Santos-Dumont was born in Brazil in
eighteen seventy-three.
He grew up around the machinery
of his family's coffee business.
In his own account, engines fascinated
him long before he ever took
to the air.
Paris gave that fascination a much
larger playground.
At the turn of the twentieth
century, he was experimenting with
balloons and powered airships.
These weren't passenger jets.
Think of a long balloon,
an engine, cables, and a pilot
suspended below it.
The city was both his backdrop
and his audience.
That is the world behind the
Santos. Not a polished airport
advertisement.
A world in which flight was
still being worked out in public.
And Santos-Dumont wasn't merely watching
it happen.
He was going up there himself.
In nineteen oh-one, Santos-Dumont flew
his Number Six airship around the
Eiffel Tower and returned to
Saint-Cloud. The challenge behind the
Deutsch Prize was a round trip
within thirty minutes.
It turned Paris into a racecourse,
with one very famous turning point.
Even the finish became a dispute
over timing.
The flight brought him the prize
and helped make him a public
figure. For our story, one detail
matters:
time wasn't an abstract number on
a dial.
It was part of the challenge.
Picture the contrast.
Down below, a gentleman could pause,
reach into a waistcoat, and consult
his watch.
Up above, the pilot had an
engine and a machine to manage.
A pocket watch could be a
beautiful object.
Accessing it was another matter.
The next step wasn't to make
a more impressive watch.
It was to make the watch
easier to use.
Santos-Dumont had a friend with a
different kind of workshop:
Louis Cartier.
Cartier's own history dates the answer
to nineteen oh-four,
when Louis created a wristwatch for
the aviator so he could consult
the time while flying.
The familiar story is wonderfully
simple.
The man working on the future
of transport brings a practical problem
to a man working on beautiful
objects. Their worlds meet at the
wrist.
There's no need to imagine an
elaborate speech between them.
The problem itself does the work.
A watch in a pocket asks
you to retrieve it.
A watch on your wrist is
already waiting where you can glance
at it.
It's the sort of change that
looks obvious after somebody has made
it.
But obvious solutions can be the
ones that travel furthest.
Cartier had given a practical need
a form people could recognize.
Now look at the design again.
The square outline gives the dial
a frame.
The numerals make it feel formal.
The visible screws give it an
unexpectedly mechanical character.
Cartier identifies the square case,
rounded corners, and exposed screws as
signatures of the Santos design.
You don't have to know a
reference number to notice that
combination.
It can look elegant and industrial
in the same glance.
That's an observation about its design,
rather than a claim that every
detail had a special flying function.
And the Santos you see today
is a family of watches,
not one object frozen in nineteen
oh-four.
Sizes, movements,
straps, and proportions have changed.
A modern bracelet model isn't
Santos-Dumont's original watch.
Still, the visual idea holds together.
Put a Santos among a row
of watches, and its outline gives
you a good chance of picking
it out before you've read the
name.
Meanwhile, Santos-Dumont's experiments
kept moving.
In nineteen oh-six, he made public
flights in Paris with the Fourteen-bis,
a heavier-than-air machine.
The Smithsonian documents these flights
as a landmark in early European
aviation.
The aircraft looks wonderfully strange
to modern eyes: a framework, wings,
wheels, and an exposed pilot.
It belongs to an age when
people could watch an unfamiliar machine
try to leave the ground, and
then see it actually do it.
This matters because the name on
the watch wasn't invented for a
collection.
Santos was a person whose flying
experiments were being seen and
discussed.
His story gave the object a
connection to the modern world taking
shape around it.
Yet airplanes wouldn't be the watch's
whole future.
In nineteen eleven, the Santos design
reached a wider market.
A solution associated with one aviator
now had a life beyond him.
At this point, you'll often hear
the Santos described as the first
wristwatch.
That's a neat headline, but the
history is longer.
The Louvre's Breguet exhibition
documents a watch designed for the
wrist that the Queen of Naples
commissioned in eighteen ten, nearly a
century earlier.
So the Santos story doesn't need
to begin with nobody ever wearing
a watch on a wrist.
Its interest lies in this particular
combination:
an aviator's practical need, Cartier's
design, and an identity that people
remembered.
The question is less,
who thought of a strap first?
More,
why did this design stay with
us?
That distinction brings us back to
the modern watch from the opening.
The flying problem explains its
beginning. But it doesn't, on its
own, explain why someone would choose
a Santos long after that problem
had disappeared.
The Santos kept changing with the
people wearing it.
In nineteen seventy-eight, Cartier
introduced a new Santos in steel
and gold with a metal bracelet.
The brand's collection record documents
that version.
The case and bracelet now formed
a much stronger visual whole.
Look at the meeting of brushed
metal, polished edges, and those exposed
screws.
In editorial terms, this is where
the story becomes especially
interesting. The watch can carry the
memory of machinery
while serving as something to wear
in everyday life.
That's different from preserving an old
instrument exactly as it was.
A lasting design has room to
adapt.
The Santos could keep its recognizable
outline while changing its presence on
the wrist.
The original practical need had become
a starting point.
The design was now doing another
job: giving the wearer a distinctive
object, with a human story attached.
Today, the Santos name covers different
approaches.
The slimmer Santos-Dumont keeps a close
visual relationship with the early
strap-watch idea.
Santos de Cartier offers bracelet models
and interchangeable straps, among other
variations.
There isn't one movement or one
size that describes the entire family.
But a family resemblance is easy
to see.
The outline.
The dial.
The screws.
Change the material or the scale,
and those details keep the conversation
going.
Here's my reading of why that
works:
the watch gives you more than
a familiar luxury name.
It offers a design you can
recognize, and an origin you can
explain in a sentence.
A pilot needed an easier way
to read the time.
That's a story people can carry
around without knowing how a movement
is assembled.
And it makes the watch's elegance
more interesting, because there's a
practical idea underneath it.
So return to the watch from
the beginning.
The Cartier Santos looks at home
under a jacket sleeve.
Its origin takes us somewhere much
less comfortable:
above Paris, in an experimental flying
machine, with a pilot who needed
his attention on the flight.
It wasn't the first time anyone
had put a watch on a
wrist. It didn't invent flight.
And today's Santos isn't the object
Santos-Dumont wore.
None of that makes the story
smaller. The striking part is that
a useful idea could keep finding
new forms,
new wearers, and new reasons to
matter.
From an aviator's problem to a
recognizable design, the watch changed
its surroundings without losing its
name.
A century later, you don't need
to fly an airship to appreciate
it. You only need to glance
at your wrist.